I'm sure many of y'all have
already heard of the molecule
DNA, and it stands for
deoxyribonucleic acid.
I wrote it out ahead of time
to spare you the pain of
watching me spell this
in real time.
But it is-- and I think you
already have an idea.
This is the basic unit of
heredity, or it's what codes
all of our genetic
information.
And what I want to do in this
video-- because I think that's
kind of common knowledge.
That's popular knowledge that,
oh, everything that makes my
hair black or my eyes blue or
whatever, that's all somehow
encoded in our DNA.
But what I want to do in this
video is give you an idea of
how something like DNA, a
molecule, can actually code
for what we are.
How does the information, one,
get stored in this type of a
molecule, then how does that
actually turn into the
proteins that make up our
enzymes and our organs and our
brain cells and everything else
that really make us us?
So this is a computer graphics
representation of DNA, and I'm
sure many of y'all have heard
of the double helix.
And that's in reference to the
structure that DNA takes.
And you can see here it's
a double helix.
As you can see here, you have
two of these lines, and
they're intertwined
with each other.
You see there, that's one of
them, and then you see another
one intertwined like that.
And then they're connected by--
you can almost view it as
like these bridges between the
two helixes, and they twist
around each other.
I think you get the idea.
So the double helix just
describes the structure, the
shape that DNA takes, and
it leads to all sorts of
interesting repercussions in
terms of how heredity takes
place and how natural selection
and variation might
take place as well.
And actually, in the future, I
do want to actually read with
you Watson and Crick's paper on
the double helix where they
essentially talk about
their discovery.
The best thing about that paper,
besides the fact that
it was probably one of the
biggest discoveries in the
history of mankind, is that the
paper is only a page and a
half long, and it goes to my
general view that if you have
something good to say,
it shouldn't take you
that long to say it.
But with that said, let's think
a little bit about how
this can actually generate the
proteins and whatever else
that make up all of us.
So right here this is a
zoomed-up version of that
graphic that I just showed you a
little bit earlier, and this
is each of the helixes.
So if this is the magenta side,
if you unwound this
helix-- right now it shows it
in its wound state, but if I
unwind this helix, one side
would maybe be this magenta
side of our helix and
then one side is
this green side, right?
And if you twist it up,
you get back to
this drawing up here.
And then these bridges that you
see in this drawing in the
double helix, those are these
connections right here.
These are the bridges.
Now, what allows us to code
information is that the blocks
that make up the bridges are
made of different molecules.
And the four different molecules
that are made up in
DNA are adenine-- and
it's written here
on this little chart.
I got all of this from
Wikipedia, so if you want more
information I encourage
you to go there.
Adenine, that's up here.
This is the molecular structure
of adenine.
It's connected to a sugar
right here, ribose.
I won't go into a deoxyribose.
And then you have your
phosphate group.
But these kind of form the
backbone of the DNA: the sugar
and the phosphate groups.
And I'm not going to go into
the microbiology of it,
because that's not important
right now to understanding
just how does this intuitively
code for what we are.
So along the backbone, which
is identical, and
we'll talk about it.
They run in different
directions.
It's called antiparallel,
so they label the ends.
And I'm not going to go into
detail there, but the
important thing are
these bases here.
So you have adenine, and adenine
pairs with thymine,
and you see that up here.
If you have an adenine molecule
here, an adenine base
here, it'll pair with
thymine, and this is
called the base pair.
Adenine and thymine pair
with each other.
If you have thymine, it's going
to pair with adenine.
And then you have guanine and
it pairs with cytosine.
And the names of these, you
should know these names, just
because they are almost-- well,
if you ever enter any
discussion about DNA
and base pairs,
this is expected knowledge.
But the names of the molecules
and how they're structured,
not important just yet.
But what's important is the fact
that there are four of
them and that they essentially
code information.
So you can view one of these
strands in kind of a
simplified way.
You can just view it as a strand
of-- so this one, if it
has an adenine and then
it has a cytosine,
then it has a guanine.
That's a guanine.
They did it in purple.
And then it has a-- oh, no, it
has a thymine, not a guanine.
So it has a thymine in
purple, and then in
blue, it has a guanine.
So this strand right
here codes ACTG.
And if you were to code the
opposite side of the strand,
you could immediately-- I don't
even have to look here.
I can look at this side and
say, OK, adenine will pair
with thymine, cytosine pairs
with guanine, thymine pairs
with adenine, and guanine
pairs with cytosine.
So they're complementary
strands.
So if you think about
it, they're really
coding the same thing.
If you have one of them, you
have all of the information
for the other.
Now, in our DNA, in a human's
DNA, you might say, hey, Sal,
how do I go from these little
chains of these molecules?
How does that turn into me?
How does that turn into
this complex organism?
And the simple answer is, well,
the human genome has
three billion of these
base pairs.
And that's actually just in
half of your chromosomes.
And I'll tell you, maybe in this
video or a future video,
why we only consider half of
your chromosomes, and that's
because essentially you have
a pair of every chromosome.
I'll talk in more detail
about that.
And this number, to some people,
they might say, it
only takes three billion base
pairs to describe who I am?
And some people would say, wow,
it takes three billion
base pairs to describe
who I am.
I never thought I was
that complex.
So depending on your point of
view, this is either a large
or small number.
But when you take these three
billion base pairs, you're
actually encoding all of the
information that it takes to
make in this case
a human being.
And actually it turns out a
lot of primates don't have
that many different base pairs
than human beings.
The amazing thing is even things
like roundworms and
fruit flies also number in a
surprisingly large fraction of
the base pairs of
a human being.
Maybe I'll do another
video where I go
into comparative biology.
But how do these base pairs
actually lead to proteins?
I mean, it's fair enough.
That's information.
It's like you can view these
as ones and zeroes in some
type of computer language, but
really they're not just ones
and zeroes, because they can
take on four different values.
They can take on an A, a T, a
C or a G, so you could think
of them as zero, ones, twos
and threes, but I won't go
into that whole aspect
of it just now.
So how does that actually
code information?
So DNA when it actually
transcribes something-- the
process is called transcription,
and I'm going
to do a pretty gross
simplification of it, but I
think it'll give you the gist of
how it codes for proteins.
So what happens when
transcription happens is that
these two strands split up, and
one of the strands-- let
me just take one of them.
Let's say it looks like this.
I'll do it all in one color.
Let's say it's just ATGGACG--
I'm just making up stuff-- TA.
Let's say that that's the strand
that got split up.
And what happens is
it transcribes--
and I won't say itself.
There's a whole bunch of enzymes
and proteins and a
whole bunch of chemical
reactions that have to happen,
but this DNA essentially
transcribes a
complementary mRNA.
And I'll introduce RNA.
It's essentially the exact same
thing as-- well, the word
is ribonucleic acid, so it's
literally-- you get rid of the
deoxy, so you can kind of say
it's got its oxy, and it's
ribonucleic acid, but it's
very similar to DNA.
It codes in the exact
same way.
The only difference between RNA,
instead of a thymine, it
has something called a uracil.
So every place where you would
have expected a thymine, you
would have expected a T,
you'll now see a U.
So, for example, if this is the
DNA strand, then an RNA,
an mRNA, in a messenger RNA
strand, will be built
complementary to this.
So it'll be built-- let's see.
With A, you'd normally have
thymine when you're talking
DNA, but now we're talking RNA,
so it'll be a uracil,
then an adenine, cytosine,
cytosine, uracil, then we got
a guanine, a cytosine,
an adenine, and then
we'll have a uracil.
So this is the mRNA
strand here.
And all of this is occurring
inside the
nucleus of your cells.
And we'll do a whole series of
videos in the future about the
structure of our cells, but I
think most of us know that our
cells-- and I'll talk more
about eukaryotic and
prokaryotic organisms in the
future, but most complex
organisms, they have a cell
nucleus where we have all of
our chromosomes that contain
all of our DNA.
And so this mRNA then detaches
itself from the DNA that it
was transcribed from, and then
it leaves the nucleus, and it
goes to these structures
called ribosomes.
I'm oversimplifying it a
little bit, but at the
ribosomes, this mRNA is
translated into proteins.
So let me do that.
So let's say this is the mRNA.
It was transcribed from that
DNA, so let me get
rid of that DNA now.
I got rid of the DNA.
This is the mRNA that we were
able to transcribe from that
DNA, and they have these
other things called
tRNA or transfer RNA.
And what these are--
and this is the
really interesting part.
So you may or may not know that
pretty much everything we
are is made up of proteins.
And these proteins, the building
blocks of proteins
are amino acids.
And for those of you who like
to lift weights, I'm sure
you've seen ads for amino
acid supplements and
things of the like.
And the reason why they talk
about amino acids is because
those are the building
blocks of proteins.
My son actually has an allergy
to milk protein, so we had to
get him a formula that was just
pure amino acids, just
all of the milk proteins
broken down.
So if you look at a protein,
it's actually a chain of these
amino acids and usually
a fairly long chain.
We'll look at some protein
structures in the very near
future, just to give you
an idea of things.
It's a very long chain of these
amino acids, and there
are actually 20 different
amino acids.
Twenty different amino acids are
pretty much the structure
of all of our proteins.
Let me write that.
So a very obvious question is
how can these things code for
20 different amino acids?
I can only have four different
things in this little bucket
right here.
And then you just have to go
back to your combinatorics, or
if you can't go back to it
to watch the playlist on
probability and combinatorics,
and say, OK, there's only four
ways that I can have for
each of these bases.
There's only four different
bases that I can have here,
either an adenine guanine,
cytosine or, depending on
whether we're talking
about DNA or RNA,
a uracil or a thymine.
But how can we increase
the combinations?
Well, if we include two of them,
if we include two bases,
then how many combinations
can we have?
Well, we have four possibilities
here, then we'd
have four possibilities here, so
we'd have 16 possibilities.
But that's still not enough.
That's still not enough to code
for one of 20 amino acids
to say, hey, this is going to
code for amino acid number
five, and we'll talk more about
their actual names.
So what do we have to do?
Well, we have to use
three of them.
So three of them, there's
actually four times four times
four possibilities here, so
they could code for 64
different things.
They could take on 64 different
combinations or
permutations, this
UAC right here.
So if we have three of these
bases, we can actually code
for an amino acid.
Actually, it's overkill, because
we can actually have
64 combinations here, and there
are only 20 amino acids,
so we can even have redundant
combinations code for
different amino acids.
For example, we might say
that, and this isn't the
actual code, but maybe UAC, and
I should look these up.
This codes for amino
acid number 1.
And if it was AAU, then this
codes for amino acid number 2.
And if I have-- I mean, I
think you get the idea.
If I have GGG, this codes for
amino acid number 10.
And what happens is when this
messenger RNA leaves the
nucleus, it goes to the
ribosomes, and at the
ribosomes-- we're going to look
at that diagram in a few
seconds-- but at the ribosomes--
let me take my
same mRNA molecule.
And they're much longer than
what I'm showing here.
This is just a fraction
of an mRNA molecule.
So I'll take my mRNA molecule,
and what they do is they
essentially act as a template
for tRNA molecules.
And tRNA molecules are these
molecules that are attached to
the-- they're almost like the
trucks for the amino acids.
So let's say I have some amino
acid right here, and then I
have another amino acid that's
right here like that, and then
I have another amino acid
that's like that.
They'll be attached
to tRNA molecules.
So let's say that this tRNA
molecule has on it-- so this
amino acid is attached to a
tRNA molecule that has the
code on it A-- let me do
it in a darker color.
It has the code AUG.
This one right here has
the code-- let me
pick another one.
Let's say it has GGAC.
So what's going to happen?
When you're in the ribosome, and
it's a complex situation,
but actually what's happening
isn't too fancy.
This tRNA, it wants to bond
to this part of the mRNA.
Why?
Because adenine bonds with
uracil, uracil bonds with
adenine, and guanine bonds with
cyotsine, so it'll pull
up right here.
It'll pull up right next to this
thing, and actually, I
should probably-- well, I don't
know if I can rotate it.
But it'll just pull up
right here and attach
to this mRNA molecule.
And this right here is tRNA.
This is mRNA.
And the names don't matter.
I really just want to give you
the big picture idea of how
the proteins are actually
formed.
And this is an amino acid.
I don't know, let's call it
amino acid 1, amino acid 5,
amino acid 20.
This guy, he's going to
pull up right here.
The guanine is attracted to the
cytosine, and if you watch
the chemistry videos, these are
actually hydrogen bonds
that form the base pairs.
Adenine, wants to pull up to
uracil, cytosine to guanine,
and so on and so forth.
And so once all of these
guys have pulled
up-- let me do that.
So once you've pulled up, let's
say that this is-- I
could do it up here.
This is my mRNA molecule.
I'm not going to draw the
specifics right there.
My little tRNA's pull up, pull
up next to it, and they each
hold a payload, right?
So this first one holds this
payload right here of this
amino acid.
The second one holds this
payload of this amino acid and
so forth and so on.
And so it might keep going,
and there's another green
amino acid here.
They really don't have those
colors, but I'm just-- just
for the sake of simplicity
like that.
And then the amino acids bond
to each other when they're
held like that close
to each other.
This doesn't happen
all by itself.
The ribosome serves a purpose,
and there are enzymes that
facilitate this process, but
once these guys bond together,
the tRNA detaches,
and you have this
chain of amino acids.
And then the chain of amino
acids starts to bend around so
they have all of these-- and
it's actually a fascinating--
I mean, people spend their lives
studying how proteins
fold, and that's actually where
they get most of their
structural properties.
It's not just the chain of the
amino acids, but what's more
important is how these amino
acids actually fold.
So once you fold them, they form
these really ultracomplex
patterns based on what amino
acid is attracted to what
other amino acid in these
very intricate
three-dimensional shapes.
And what I took here from
Wikipedia is these are some
amino acids.
And just to be able to relate
this to the DNA, this right
here is insulin.
It's key in our ability to
process glucose in our body.
So this right here is insulin.
It's a hormone.
So sometimes you hear people
talk about your immune system.
Sometimes you hear people
talking about your endocrine
system and hormones, sometimes
your digestive system.
This is hemoglobin, what
essentially transports our
oxygen in our blood.
But all of these things are
proteins, and all these
little, little folds you see,
these are all little amino-- I
mean, they're just little
dots of amino acids.
Some of these are multiple
chains of amino acids kind of
fitting together like a big
puzzle, but some of them or
just single chains
of amino acids.
For insulin right here, this
is 50 amino acids.
And then once the chain forms,
it all bundles together and
forms this little blob like you
see, but the shape of that
blob is super important for
insulin being able to perform
the function that it needs to
perform in our systems.
But this right here is
approximately 50-- I forgot
the exact number--
amino acids.
This right here, this
immunoglobulin G, which is
part of our immune
system, this is
roughly 1,500 amino acids.
So how much DNA or how
many base pairs
had to code for this?
Well, three times
as much, right?
Because you have to have three
base pairs that code for one
amino acid, and actually, three
base pairs, this is
called a codon, because it
codes for amino acids.
So three base pairs
make a codon.
So if you have 50 amino acids
that make up insulin, that
means you're going to have to
have 50 codons, which means
you have to have 150 bases
or 150 of these
A's and G's and T's.
If you have 1,500 amino acids,
that means you're going to
have to have 1,500 codons, which
means you're going to
have roughly 4,500 of these base
pairs that code for it.
Now, there are some notions that
get confused a lot, so I
went to kind of the smallest
level of our DNA right here,
and this is the level at which--
well, this is RNA that
I'm pointing to right there, but
this is the smallest level
of DNA, and that's the level
at which the information is
actually coded.
But how does that relate to
things like genes and
chromosomes and things
that you might talk
about in other contexts?
So let's say the 150 base pairs
that coded for insulin,
these make up a gene.
And these 4,500 base pairs
make up another gene.
Now, all of the genes don't make
proteins, but all of the
proteins are made by genes.
So let's say I have just a
bunch of-- I'll just make
another A, G, and it goes down,
down, down, and you have
a T and then a C and a
C, and let's say I
have 4,500 of these.
These could code
for a protein.
These could code for protein,
or they could have all of
these other kind of regulatory
functions telling what other
parts of the DNA should and
should not be coded and how
the DNA behaves, so it becomes
super, super complex.
But this kind of section of our
DNA, this is what we refer
to as a gene, and a gene can
have anywhere from a couple of
hundreds of these base pairs
or these bases to several
thousand of these base pairs.
Now, a gene is that part of our
chromosome that codes for
a particular protein or serves
a certain function.
Now, there are different
versions of genes.
It's a gross oversimplification,
but let me
say this is the gene
for insulin.
Now, there might be slight
variations in how insulin can
be coded for, and I'm kind of
going out of my domain right
here, because I don't
know if that's true.
And maybe I shouldn't just
speak specifically about
insulin, but it's coding for
some protein, but there's
maybe multiple different
ways that that
protein can be coded.
Maybe instead of a T here,
sometimes there's a C there.
It still codes for
the same protein.
It doesn't change it quite
enough, but that protein acts
just a little bit different.
It's a slight variant.
I'll use that word.
Now, each variant of this gene
is called an allele.
It's a specific variant
of your gene.
Now, if you take this DNA chain,
and this chain over
here-- let's see.
This is one base pair.
This might be like one base.
This is another base.
Maybe this is an adenine and
then this would be a thymine
over here in green.
This is an adenine and this
would be a thymine.
If right here this is a guanine,
then right here would
be a cytosine.
This would be just a
very small section.
If I were to like zoom out, and
let's say we have a big
chain of DNA where each of these
little dots are a base
pair that I'm drawing here,
maybe this section
codes for gene 1.
And then there's some noise or
things that we haven't fully
understood yet.
Now, I want to be clear.
Just with a simple discussion of
DNA, we're already kind of
approaching the frontiers of
what we know and what we don't
know, because DNA is hugely
complex, and there's all of
these feedback structures, and
certain genes tell you to code
for other genes and not to code
for other genes and to
code under certain
circumstances, hugely complex.
So there's huge sections of
DNA that we still don't
understand what exactly
they do.
But then maybe they'll have
another section here that
codes for gene 2.
Maybe gene 2 is a little
bit longer.
Maybe it's 1,000 base pairs.
But when you take all of these
and you turn it into a-- it
kind of winds in on
itself like this.
Let me do it.
So it'll wind up, winding in on
itself like this and do all
sorts of crazy things.
Remember, it completely bundles
itself up, and then it
looks something like that.
Then you get a chromosome.
And just to get an idea of how
large a chromosome is compared
to the actual base pairs,
chromosome number one in the
human genome-- so we
have 23 pairs.
If you look at it inside of a
nucleus-- so let's say that's
the nucleus.
Let's say this is the cell.
The cell is much bigger
than what I'm showing.
But we have 23 pairs
of chromosomes.
I won't do all of them.
You can actually see
chromosomes in a
not-too-expensive microscope, so
we're already getting to a
scale that we can start
to look at.
But the largest chromosome,
which is chromosome number one
in the human genome, just to
give an idea of how much
information it's packing, that
thing right there has 220
million base pairs.
Sometimes people talk about
chromosomes and genetics and
genes and base pairs
interchangeably, but it's very
important to kind of get
an idea of scale.
These chromosomes are a
super-long strand of DNA
that's all configured and
bundled up, and it contains
220 million base pairs.
So the actual elements that are
coding for the information
are unbelievably small
relative to
the chromosome itself.
But now that we understand a
little bit, and actually I
want to take a look back at
this, because this kind of
blows my mind, that if you
just take those little
combinations of those amino
acids, you can form these very
intricate, very advanced
structures that we're still
fully understanding how they
actually interact with each
other and regulate how all of
our biological processes work.
And what's even more amazing is
that this scheme that I've
talked about in this video about
DNA to mRNA to tRNA to
these molecules, this is true
for all of life on our planet,
so we all share this
same mechanism.
Me and this plant, we share
that common root
that we all have DNA.
As different as me and that
roach that I might not like to
be in the same room, we all
share that same common root of
DNA and that all of it codes to
proteins in this exact same
way, that there's this
commonality amongst all life.
That, to me, is mind blowing.
Then even more mind blowing is
how these very complex shapes
are formed by the DNA.
And this isn't speculation.
This is observed behavior.
This is a fascinating structure
right here, but it's
just based on 20 amino acid--
you can almost view the amino
acid as the LEGOS, and you put
the LEGOS together, and just
the chemical interactions form
these fairly impressive
structures right here.
So now that we know a little bit
about DNA and how it codes
into protein, we can take a
little jump back and talk a
little bit more about how
variation is actually
introduced into a population.